[Música]
Bienvenidos a esta Crónica especial de
cultura dedicada al Centenario de la
entrada en la tumba de Tutankamón y para
ello nos acompaña Alba Santana en el
estudio periodista de la redacción de
Francia 24 Buenos días Alba buenos días
Rosa sí Bueno pues no es
teletransportamos a ese noviembre de
1922 que es un mes básicamente histórico
Por qué Porque descubrieron la primera
tumba de la realeza del Antiguo Egipto
prácticamente intacta porque digo
prácticamente Porque después veremos que
que sí que fue violada en un par de
ocasiones Bueno antes que nada estamos
aquí en el Valle de los reyes en Luxor
en Egipto Y tenemos a Un arqueólogo y
artista de formación Howard Carter que
está a las órdenes de lord garbón que es
quien financió esta expedición y Carter
Ya llevaba cinco años en el valle de Los
Reyes Sin haber encontrado absolutamente
nada y un día de repente se dio el 4 de
noviembre de 19 22 un niño por
casualidad según cuenta la historia que
todos tienen consenso que se llamaba
José se tropezó con una piedra mientras
llevaba agua a los trabajadores de la
expedición y bueno fue y se lo dijo al
supervisor le dijo que había encontrado
algo y bueno lo que había encontrado no
era algo era la tumba de Tutankamón
Entonces hasta el 26 de noviembre no
entraron en la tumba porque Carter tuvo
que consultar con su mecenas el hecho de
entrar a por primera vez y bueno cuando
lo consiguieron cuando entraron a esa
tumba fueron los primeros Él y su equipo
en pisar este mausoleo en cerca de 3.300
años algo histórico y Carter dijo Cuando
entró veo cosas maravillosas y es que
realmente estaba viendo cosas
maravillosas estaba viendo cuatro salas
repletas de objetos de Preciado valor y
que tardaron más o menos 10 años en
poder
restaurar completamente Bueno ahora
pasamos al interior de la tumba del
faraón había 16 peldaños hacia abajo la
primera puerta un pasillo y después
pasamos directamente a la segunda puerta
que esta Es realmente importante porque
porque aquí estaban los símbolos del
saqueo porque había sido doblemente
sellada eso significa que entraron al
menos en dos ocasiones y saquearon gran
parte del Bueno entonces estamos en la
antecámara donde tenían materiales de
embalsamaje del faraón aproximadamente
600 objetos diversos después una pequeña
sala conocida como anexo donde también
había objetos diversos pero no pocos al
menos 2.000 de diferentes valores y
bueno lo que diríamos en la Joya de la
corona la cámara del sarcófago donde
encontraron a Tutankamón allí bueno Y
esta cámara es especialmente importante
porque nos demuestra algo y es que solo
había motivos del libro de los muertos
pintadas en las paredes de esta sala y
normalmente los faraones más importantes
tenían absolutamente toda la tumba
cubierta de motivos del libro de los
muertos para desearle suerte en su viaje
al más allá esto nos demuestra que
Tutankamón pasó sin mucha pena ni Gloria
por su reinado Bueno tal como nos
comentabas fue un niño egipcio no el que
dio por casualidad con esta tumba que
nos muestras Qué papel tuvieron los
locales y este papel como
respondió a la historia en un momento en
que Egipto era Colonia británica Sí
exactamente
fue un niño egipcio o no No lo sabemos
si esta historia es cierta Pero bueno lo
importante es que Carter contó con un
gran equipo que lo ayudó y la mayoría de
sus trabajadores eran egipcios al menos
50 trabajadores que quedaron
absolutamente opacados Ya que en las
fotos de la expedición ni siquiera se
marcaban sus nombres Bueno entonces esto
enfureció bastante a los egipcios que
llevamos aquí un recorrido histórico y
bueno retrato un poco ese retrato de
aventurero en inglés el arqueólogo
colono que Bueno al final si la
participación de estos egipcios el
hallazgo no podría haber sido posible y
al final es su patrimonio y precisamente
Qué pasó con los objetos que se
encontraron en la tumba bueno tenemos
que tener en mente que se extraen cerca
de
5.900 objetos diversos la gran mayoría
se quedaron en Egipto esto es cierto los
más icónicos los que todos recorda bueno
Uno de ellos es la máscara de oro de
Tutankamón que ha salido en decenas de
películas que todos hemos visto y sobre
la que se especuló porque tenía agujeros
para los pendientes entonces pensaron
que podría ser incluso de una mujer
bueno otros objetos eran el sarcófago el
piramidón que es la puntita de la
pirámide el trono de oro el manicure o
el vaso canopo donde se embalsamaban los
restos órganos vitales para la
momificación y daremos un poco en la
figura de Tutankamón porque como nos
decías no pareciera que fuera un faraón
muy importante a pesar de la leyenda que
se ha construido a su alrededor Sí es
que a ver aquí tenemos que recordar Que
obviamente el factor más determinante es
este hallazgo de la primera tumba
prácticamente intacta que permitió que
la investigación fuera gigantesca
Entonces el otro factor que genera mucho
interés entre la población es todas las
historias en torno a Tutankamón y a su
familia Él es polémico hijo del rey
akenatón que cambió nada más y nada
menos que la religión del país pasó de
ser politeísta a monoteísta y solo
adorar al rey del sol además Tutankamón
solo vivió 19 años algo que también
suele generar bastante interés y sus
padres eran hermanos algo que hizo que
su salud fuera delicada y que los
investigadores han demostrado que fue
una de las razones por las que murió
joven tenía un sistema inmunológico
débil una enfermedad ósea y bueno
también tenía malaria en el momento en
el que lo encontraron precisamente no
esta muerte prematura que ha inspirado
tantos mitos misterios no hay una
leyenda que dura ya más de un siglo Alba
Muchísimas gracias por este repaso de la
figura de Tutankamón y a ustedes
Muchísimas gracias por su atención sigan
con nosotros
[Música]